I am NOT popular on Instagram at all
today I'm asking a bunch of people that
I work with a bunch of you like don't
work with anyone I can think of I'm
asking them to flood my Instagram with
notifications so have you ever turned on
your notifications like on to my phone
yeah like push notifications yes so
that's what I had at the beginning of
when I started fun speed and then I was
in a video that like popped off
and then I turn those things off still
not to giving me push notification
so Spencer gets push notifications on
Instagram which means it's possible I'm
gonna add my account to Spencer's phone
my concern is why does yours work and
none of know literally know what else he
does two minutes till fresh content
let's do this oh you need to follow
Spencer right now this is really making
me rethink the content I have a
[Music]
remember I didn't like so much on my
life it looks pretty cool it looks like
a waterfall and it's funny because we
called it a flood Spencer got a lot of
attention today which she probably loved
right thank you everybody
[Music]
[Music]